you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
i don't think i'm alone in this a lot of
us have been sitting around more since
cove had started
and
now things are starting to open up we're
all getting out and doing things
i'm in quebec i'm in canada and for a
while we weren't even supposed to go
outside except for within certain hours
of the day
and then
i have dogs and there was an exception
for anyone with dogs you can you can be
with your dog taking on a walk
it was
that sort of extreme
lockdown only happened for a little bit
and then people realize that's that's
kind of crazy people need to go outside
and get fresh air but
honestly i stopped going outside nearly
as much as i used to i just kind of got
into this lazy habit and now i'm going
out and doing stuff do i need to be
careful when i'm running around
like could i now break a bone easier
than before
does atrophy happen that quickly
uh actually can happen that quickly but
you're a young guy and you probably
don't have to worry about it to that
point if it was
um like an 80 year old woman who's been
like i'm gonna go and start jogging
tomorrow like i'd be like and chill out
grandma like just take it slow at the
beginning and you know and give your
bones a chance to catch up i think you
don't really actually have anything to
worry about but
that is a good point because i mean
myself included i've been sitting on you
know sitting a whole lot more i've been
inside the whole time and while i'm in
germany right now
um or before at the beginning of the
lockdown we had pretty much the same
thing but they gave us an hour of
outside time not actually enforceable
obviously but
they basically said the same thing you
know everyone's allowed an hour but you
have to be masked and you have to do
this and you have to do that and and in
the end you know i fell into a rut where
i didn't move much either
i know that remodeling of bones is
happening constantly there was there was
an interview with chris hadfield who's
the astronaut the canadian astronaut
he was saying that the first week that
you're in space you just pee out
calcium because your bones are trying to
remodel they don't know what's happening
in the zero gravity so being inside long
periods of time
and not doing much and being quite
sedentary
uh has actually two two digits um and it
impacts your bones in two ways first
you're actually not getting enough
vitamin d because you're in your inside
which is horrible for your mood it
causes all it's been linked to
depression and all that kind of stuff
but it's also been super linked to
your bone not knowing how to metabolize
your calcium so say you're getting
enough calcium it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you don't have the
metabolically active version of vitamin
d
which means any calcium you're taking in
you are pee right now and good luck like
it won't actually it won't actually help
you so that's the first and horrible you
know impact to our bones uh from staying
inside then the second thing is that
yeah your muscles are not acting on your
bones they're not giving you that
pressure they're not telling your bones
hey i'm being used please keep
remodeling this area as were
our skeleton is always trying to
optimize itself it takes away from areas
that aren't being used and adds to areas
that are being used so if you're not
using your legs all the time or
your arms or you know you're not
exercising it's not great for your
skeleton your skeleton's like oh okay i
heard you really don't need this stuff
let's let's lighten the load the our
ephemeron like the top of the femur
where it hits or inserts into the hip
it has all these struts
that are
optimized for our type of walking
and it distributes the the pressure well
from you know hitting into the hip and
also back into the femur so you know so
you don't snap off your
femoral head which is a really bad
injury
so it's it's a yeah so it's a good way
to distribute so we have all these
struts too and they've shown that yeah
okay the struts and runners look
different than the struts and you know
your average joe that just maybe walks
to work so we look different on the
inside depending on what we're doing and
those definitely remodel over our
lifetime so that's so neat the skeleton
sort of acts like an intelligent system
right it's it's it's finding ways to
optimize itself
is this all do we understand
i mean i guess we don't understand all
the rules that are happening but this
this must just be happening as
individual cells are communicating with
each other and just obeying
fairly simple rules like if then
statements essentially if you think
about it programming totally yeah yeah
how many mysteries are there
do you think that we still just don't
understand or
has has that communication system been
well understood like do we know the if
then
um to a pretty big extent yes in some
ways because we have a lot of drugs that
act on these if then statements
basically like if right if hormone
rankle is present uh osteoblast is
deactivated if osteoblast is deactivated
it turns off its like system it's
basically like coding it's exactly like
biological coding right so when one cell
turns off its system it changes its keys
and it can no longer be activated can
only be activated when you turn on a
different key and that kind of stuff has
actually been mapped out relatively well
in humans yeah because of the way we
want drugs to act we want to understand
how our kidneys function our bones and
our skeletons actually super intertwined
with our kidneys our liver our adrenal
system
um and recently there was a paper that
came out i think it was last year that
showed that
the um
the skeleton is involved in your
fight-or-flight response which i thought
was super cool yeah
yeah so because our skeleton is tied in
with how our kidneys work and other
hormones are actually produced in
the skeleton uh apparently one of those
is uh
is responsible for your like flight
response which i thought was super cool
yeah
wow so there's a lot of stuff that's
still to be discovered like this which
was just discovered last year or well
was just published last year and then
other things that are pretty well known
like our remodeling cycle is pretty well
known we know how to kind of try to slow
it down so that people you know will
increase estrogen in older women and
that helps slow down the over remodeling
so that only happened because we
actually understand that system quite
well well that's it for this clip but
don't worry i post clips regularly and
every thursday i post completely fresh
content make sure you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome